eca dépêche toi tu vas être en retard
trop bien papa c'est mon p'tit déj
préféré le petit déj de ceux qui ont un
appétit de mons regarde là elles
marchent comme une reine et les cas
faire mal ici
à
[Musique]
c'est quoi tout ça roman sparta billet
on a été mon stack quoi regarde ça vient
de notre hymne calvaire
[Musique]
ta grand-mère carlotta et les autres y
vivent encore ta vraie mère était un
monstre à luz qu'est ce qu'on attend
[Musique]
15 verra je n'ai jamais vu ce citoyen en
ville 500 pape
pourtant j'ai mis du dire d'oran ce
matin et dont je suis à mon petit fils
mais qu'est ce que tu fais là c'est ta
mère c'est ça pour moi ça il ya eu une
explosion et les gens disparaissent
mystérieusement
[Musique]
ah ah
vous êtes un meurtrier attraper les
[Applaudissements]
bravo tu veux du thé de grenouilles tout
frais
[Musique]